good morning ladies indian twin let's
start with an introduction i am a bberry
and this is my free do hurry and where
his students from kroger high school if
you have no idea why you're sitting
quoris we're here to share the voice of
crag were high students in the red zone
for eagle project so we would like to
take a moment to explain our earthquake
experience in relation to what we would
like kai point to be in the future so
when I moved to copy in 2009 I knew very
little about Kai boys heritage social
culture and landscape even after moving
to KY boy I kept it hitting the same
school aurelius school which is in
Belfast and no one of my family got
involved in any local clubs when the
September earthquake struck we noticed
how connected and supporting the
community came together to help each
other however I felt like my family
couldn't get into such spirit support
and comfort because I had disconnected
we were from the community due to a lack
of knowledge and relationships so I
believe we need to help the families who
don't feel so connected in the community
by giving them greater opportunities to
explore their Township and I know from
experience that would have really helped
my family and the following posters like
months I myself also moved to carpool
during my childhood in late two thousand
six we moved to New Zealand from England
originally we were looking back Alfred
but my family and I were drawn to the
closing welcoming community of cowboy on
my 12th birthday was a special 115 birth
thoughts what should have been a day to
celebrate the memory let's go let's
write the life-changing earthquake
happened on my birthday despite this I
still enjoyed my day but after the
excitement wore off the impact of the
earthquake hit our house one half and it
would took two years for the council to
finally read
after the emotional demolish Minh we
built a new house and sovereign palms
during this experience I witnessed my
family grow in numbers but not by blood
so Wall Street became my new family I
want the community to have such
relations but without the natural
disaster to influence influence
encourage others so from the 11th to the
top of March a 3d model of red zone why
mccurdy was located at Kaiba high school
cheering during the two days a hundred
and seventy-five students ranging in age
between 11 and 18 viewed the model and
provided their feedback in the form of
313 Flags arrows narrowed down their
business and recreation with the two
biggest aspects kaiapoi students wanted
to see Vulcan Kylie red zones over a
hundred and forty ideas would towards
business and 94 recreation the students
also pointed out to us that the main
areas of concern that they believed to
be focused on is Chi police and clap
yourself
from here the people chose exactly what
they wanted within the two aspects we
have chosen the top three wanted ideas
to share for business we have food and
beverages first retail and services next
and lastly is commercial recreation for
recreation sports facilities was voted
first by miles second was a dog park and
third as a playground / park we can
provide examples of these at the end of
the presentation so why did people
choose this lack of it accessibility to
such facilities need for more activities
and places to explore so we can see
crack we succeed and grow into a more
vibrant community closer to home vector
and attaining to a wider range of ages
and ethnicities and from this we can see
the great results within the community
such as accessibility patents which
means the facilities are being used
frequently boredom slowly diminishes and
results enough decline and bad / illegal
behavior allows us to explore and learn
in a safe familiar environment and we
have a sense of pride and nostalgia when
we look back to our teenage years now is
your time to ask us any questions
evening be thank you for your time and
listening to our voice